hello everyone
and welcome to another let's play of
plague
inc today
we are going to be doing the necrovirus
as you can see i have been practicing
quite a bit
i'm going to be doing this on brutal and
the plague's name is of course
the cure i'm going to start this in
saudi arabia
because of the land mass that surrounds
it
my strategies have changed since my last
let's play
and the first
transmission method that i will be using
will be bats
as they are extremely hard to detect
and i want to stave off the cure
of my cure for as long
as possible now as in the last let's
play i will be referring to
my plague as a plague
or a zombie virus because as
you all know there is a cure in this
game
and it is the opposite of what i want to
achieve
now i have achieved maximum
infectivity with bats which should
help me along quite nicely
now drug resistance is important
as it is a global
advantage especially in
higher income countries
this is quite slow at the beginning as
i don't really get that many disease
points at this stage
but in the later game i will
so i just got an insomnia mutation
normally i would cut this off
but as you will see in the later game
the cure is not that much of a threat
and the reason for that will become
apparent
now if i just keep on top of popping
these bubbles
to get some disease points up
you will see very soon why that reason
is
now the infection in my home country
seems to be
picking up nicely some extremely nice
exponential growth going on there
saliva ii which is very essential
in creating
what i'm about to create
now
shutting down seaports this early in the
game is
bad
but the plague has spread to other
locations so
i think i'll manage
cold resistance is also very important
as
greenland and canada
also finland norway and sweden
they're all cold countries which
on brutal mode you really need cold
resistance of some
kind to make any sort of dent
finally water to propagate it more
through boats
and increase my chance of infecting
countries that only have sea ports
such as the caribbean greenland
madagascar
now the infection really starts to take
hold
as you can see there was a massive
infection spike
now i wonder should i just
save my disease points
because a lot needs to be done in a
short space of time to really take
advantage
of this type of plague
let's pop these
and the infection is spreading quite
nicely throughout russia
just double checking
now there are points in this map where
it will be
impossible to infect with a traditional
plague
but i think it's getting close
to revealing why that isn't an issue
with this type of plague
let me just pop these final bubbles here
yes 88 disease points
should be enough
now
immediately select these and get all the
way
to drifting fermentation which is of
course very important
as you can see on the left hand side
that is an active ability
and because i've chosen drifting
fermentation
i can send my undead army
across the sea to previously unreachable
areas
now
i have slowed down time a little bit
because timing
is crucial at this point and there will
be a lot of pop-ups
to take care of
so as you can see
i can now command a small portion of
zombies to actually cross
water to reach
other cities and populated areas
which will cause havoc and spread
the infection even further gunshots in
the background there
like my zombies are doing their intended
purpose
which is always good
greenland isn't very infected
and i have to infect sweden as well
so the z-com project now that is
a very bad sign
i will need to overrun them
because they actually kill zombies they
are
a branch of the military designed for
dispatching my
minions which is never good
at all as you can see there is a lot of
zombie outbreak pop-ups that i need to
deal with right now
whilst still staying off the oh that's a
lot of problems
whilst still staying off the cure
now i'm just bolstering
the strength of my zombies now because
if they are to destroy the zcom stations
they need to have some more abilities
they need to be stronger
i'm just sending more to greenland
because the infection is
very slow in greenland and it also has a
zcom station so it really is
key that i get rid of greenland
as soon as possible there is another
zcom station
that i'm fairly confident will get
annihilated quite quickly
as you can see oh seven million
looks like that z-com station is going
to fall extremely quickly
now the usa and canada
seem to be infecting extremely slowly
regardless of the fact that i used
that medicine upgrade
but with a bit of luck they will
pick up a little bit because luckily
they do not have zeecom stations
as you can see the zcom station in
finland
has fallen and i'm just sending more
zombies
to greenland
just to make sure the z-com station
falls
i have sent quite a bit of zombies so
it should only be a matter of time
before that happens
and even though i am actually sending
zombies away from canada it seems to be
picking up
rather nicely and zcom is down
in greenland which is a very good
turn of events canada seems to be
exponentially getting affected
which is always good
cold wave in sweden i imagine that's
because
everyone is dead or undead
as the case may be
[Music]
i sometimes try humor but it rarely if
ever works
so it should only be a matter of time
before everyone
has succumbed to my cure
the cure has destroyed humanity
i hope you've all enjoyed this zombie
themed let's play
i hope to see you all again next time
and as always
i am the cure
you